maggie haberman's story she's number 10.
uh maggie writes an exclusive here
of
trump communicating with kim jong-un
apparently these two
bros are still having a bromance they
still love each other well you know i i
wouldn't be opposed to him going on his
first date or i guess it would be a
second date
with kim jong-un in north korea would
you i mean i'm all for it hell i'd pay
for the ticket let's do that let's put
enough [ __ ] scratch together let's do
a gofundme
to send grandpa poopy pants to go have a
a a love vacation with this [ __ ] with
his bromance out in north korea
what the [ __ ] is he still talking to
this guy for
i thought they broke up didn't they
break up didn't we see this in the
[ __ ] variety or whatever the [ __ ]
tabloids are they broke up they don't
like each other hey look who's popping
in here
good morning
good morning yeah
say hi to gabe everybody hi hi hi hi we
just got off the christina bob um story
and that now we're now we're focusing in
on
the the great headline writer maggie
haberman
the last week she's been
trashed because she was writing really
shitty headlines which i don't think she
actually writes the headlines for her
stories i'm not sure exactly how that
works but but um um here the story is
that she's got here with axios is that
um apparently
donald trump's misses his lover kim
jong-un and they're still um
in this uh little spat back and forth
they want to
you know they want to
continue their bromance what do you
think about this it's not
it's not surprising
right
okay yeah i do want to kind of go on i
just want to get onto a soapbox for a
second yeah sure uh journalists writers
who do this
i
i don't have that much of an
appreciation for right because
you've got you mean this story in
particular these types of stories it's
these types of stories where all of a
sudden they drop this news in a book
meanwhile they ignored everything that
was happening during the presidency to
reveal these details right
like these so what so what you're saying
is is that they've concealed this so
that way they can sell a book right
exactly if you look at what happened
during the pandemic you know you've got
uh
uh
the
the details of what trump was doing
behind the scenes for covid wasn't
released until it was in the book right
right and so when i see like it's great
you know go get yours or whatever try to
you know get your money but at the same
time like if you're not revealing
details about something in the
presidency that affects millions of
people
then there's something to be said there
and i don't
i think what you're saying and and i
hear you're saying is it a free press
when they're doing that like are they
skating their responsibility of actually
reporting stories
right and so when i see this stuff i
look at i'm like okay great you were
able to get inside scoop into something
that you know if someone is trying to
flush down
classified documents or confidential
documents any documents
right like the fact that that is being
done is just ludicrous but if it's a
president who's trying to do that and
you have not reported on it
and you know it yeah you know i have a
big issue with that and the same thing
is that again of like what happened
during covet where it's like oh yeah
well this and these details were
revealed about tests is that why bob
woodward is trending is that why because
that possibly i don't know bob woodward
was trending i put him on the list um
and i think that maybe that's why
because bob woodward did a lot of those
interviews with trump in january
february and march and if he
where he was saying the exact opposite
of what he was saying in public because
he didn't want his supporters to know
what he actually felt right i mean he's
lies to these people he's not talking to
us
but in a way it is lying because you're
withholding the truth right you know it
and you now have said to yourself i'm
going to hold back these details because
it's later going to go in a book i'm
going to sell for money right and that's
not going to be impressed right right i
mean i'm not going to be able to sell
that book because it's already been
released so there's nothing maybe like
you know there's not going to be no
substance of juicy details no gossip
nothing that's gonna lure a reader in to
say i will buy that book
but then you have a year months later
and they're like oh hey by the way they
were doing this thing well why the [ __ ]
weren't you reporting on it when you had
all these uh these conversations in
private
well that's that's because these details
are worth a lot of [ __ ] profit right
you know and that's maybe the problem
that we have right now with the press
and this trump loop right like they they
report on [ __ ] with biden like this
inflation thing they're losing their
minds over inflation like well of course
we have heavy inflation we came out of a
[ __ ] manufacturing and production
[ __ ] depression basically right
during covid like of course the number
is gonna be [ __ ] high it's gonna be
good like it it it is gonna be high and
and yes we do have inflation but there
was things that democrats in the
president united states did to try to to
keep that under control which was the
inflation protection with the child tax
credit now not all americans were going
to receive inflation are that inflation
protection but the idea was to give
american families
a flush of money so that way it could
spread around that's how the economy
works right when people have money they
spend it when they spend it it helps you
it helps me you know that's how an
economy works and and because the
economy is heated because we were in
this production um
and really
a demand depression now we have high
demand it's heated but and it's not easy
for the american people when they have
the incomes that they have but this is
why we have to have all these
conversations about who are we going to
put in government to make sure that when
this [ __ ] arises that someone's there to
[ __ ] do the right thing not flush
documents down the [ __ ] toilet right
like how dumb do you have to be to think
you can flush a document down a toilet
and it's not gonna [ __ ] bring [ __ ]
back up at you right like figuratively
and literally like it's gonna back up
the toilet and you're gonna have to
[ __ ] put a snake down there and
[ __ ] pull out it and then they're
gonna say why why is all this paper here
and they're like don't worry about it
don't worry about it you know those
signs that say like do not flush down
female hygienic products uh you know
like uh disposable wipes or paper now
sign makers have to add
classified documents to that list
because that's a it's whenever you
whenever you see those signs where it's
like don't do this thing right in this
area it's because somebody did that
right right they didn't think they had
to make a sign or a warning or a label
before that and then somebody said in
the oval office [ __ ] there's going to
be a sign oh yeah mr president mrs
president
you know madame president whatev
whatever it would say
please do not flush classified doc
classified documents do not go here you
think there's going to be like i think
there's going to be i wouldn't
please wash
i'm just saying like maybe there's going
to be an image that comes out shortly
where assad says do not flush classified
documents sounds like sounds like
someone might have found a video
somewhere on the obscure internet i
don't know this is crazy because we were
talking about this this morning right
when this story broke because we heard
the story about the 15 boxes down at
mar-a-lago on the national archives and
apparently the national archives has
done some kind of referral to department
of justice right over the handling of
these documents which is not good for
trump or anyone else who [ __ ] helped
him with whatever they did with these
documents right and and of course this
[ __ ] idiot you sent me this statement
um and and if you want you can put it up
here we'll look at it um i'll show the
statement because i think it's
significant and the reason why is
because number one he didn't write it
number two
number two he directed someone to say
certain things in that thing about fake
news and all this [ __ ] and i'm said
earlier we you have to start when he
says this is fake news and it's not real
you have to start with okay that's the
truth right literally that's where we
start if there is denial from him the
assumption 100 of the time because it
ends up being true is that it is
actually real news right well i was even
saying earlier that sometimes like when
he fell when he accidentally told the
truth you know because he accidentally
tells the truth sometimes right right
right i i would be it was kind of mind
[ __ ] me because i'm like wait a second
that's actually true but he's saying it
it gets you all [ __ ] up because he
literally he just can't help it he can't
help himself but to admit through
projection right exactly about these
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's absolutely
insanity
and i mean i mean um you posted the
picture the other day uh apparently is
what these boxes were outside the white
house is that confirmed that that that's
the the documents and the boxes that
we're taking tomorrow
i don't know if that's confirmed that
those are the boxes because it looks
like those were i mean it could have
been uh i i just saw that and i was like
oh this is it i mean it certainly looks
like more than 15 boxes that's what i
was going to say right it's a lot more
than 15 now to be fair some of them
might be like personal possessions and
the national archives had to go down and
sort through a bunch of [ __ ] in the
attic of that [ __ ] run-down golf club
that he's got down in down in south
florida
you know knock the dust off of them and
figure out which ones are which
right i mean like i would you know i
i feel i do have uh a little bit of
uh remorse for the uh
and like
sympathy for
the the national archives people who
actually have to go through that stuff
because i was chatting with you this
morning and i'm like well i'm already
as i'm already in the in the process of
writing a sketch about the things that
they found lo and behold i get a new
detail which is that this dumb [ __ ]
decided that he was gonna try to flush
down actual papers down the toilet
so i was like i you know again it's one
of those things where i look at i'm like
oh can you guys
uh
[Music]
just stop writing this stuff for me
because you're
you're [ __ ] it all up yeah i like i'm
adding little details here and there of
like possible things and then you go and
just dump this [ __ ] on me and tell me
that you literally literally yeah trying
to [ __ ] down the toilet
uh yes and i told you you got to take it
to a 30. like we thought like 18 or 20
is a level but right now with with the
[ __ ] that's coming out and the [ __ ] that
will come out
because this isn't gonna stop this [ __ ]
isn't gonna stop it isn't gonna stop
getting worse and it's gonna get much
worse than this we're gonna go what in
the actual [ __ ]
i mean
omarosa is trending too
right
because omarosa they're like i saw
someone sweet this morning that was like
man she warned everyone i guess in her
[ __ ] book she said this right yeah
she she said all this stuff she she gave
a warning and no one listened to it
because they're like oh it's omarosa and
apprentice and blah blah blah she's
crazy there's no way this is true okay
well
well we live in a different [ __ ]
timeline i mean it just this is what we
have to deal with yeah
okay here's the omarosa timeline here
are the thread right let's see what we
got
uh
dude is there a video of her saying it
somewhere uh look here we are hey i
didn't see a video but what i did see
was a uh snapshot somebody took a
screenshot from the book
okay well here's amy uh in her new
memoir
unhinged the former white house advisor
omarosa claims she
once saw president donald trump eat a
piece of paper
in the oval office which is [ __ ]
weird
yeah i mean
have you ever looked at a piece of paper
and you're like
yummy delicious what you know it's
definitely a new source of fiber you
know
but what i will say is when i
when i
whenever i've seen someone eat a piece
of paper it's always been in some movie
and it's always a gag
like you know maybe make some gag but it
was always a gag like a joke that they
were like disposing of the evidence and
so they were like what are you doing in
the
right so what there is a movie with that
what what a movie
i was talking about earlier about the
good fellas when the feds come to the
house and she's flushing the drugs down
the toilet right
uh what movie is that i know what you're
talking about they stick the paper in
their mouth i know
uh
you know that's a good question i know
when liar liar he stuffs paper in his
mouth he doesn't eat it
um
is that what it is
yeah okay well that there's anything
i'm also finding a gif of jimmy fallon
as
trump eating piece of paper so
it was a thing this is but this is not
this is from a while ago i would imagine
right it's probably is this the uh is
this the screenshot
here yeah yeah that's the one
okay it says others could be truly gone
forever and i think she's talking about
documents is that what she's talking
about here in 2018 omarosa shared her
book unhinged
she revealed
chewed and swalled a note
after a meeting with michael cohen what
the [ __ ] right so this is what she's
writing in her book yeah
and this is the an excerpt um explains
because trump's notorious germaphobia so
that's what she's saying is he's a
germaphobe which is insane to think that
you would if you're a germaphobe you
would eat something well
see i don't actually think he's a
germaphobe right right you know i don't
think i think he's like i don't want pez
guys the guy's been peed on i doubt he's
a german right right he's like i don't i
don't want the peasants to touch me
right right exactly i don't want peasant
juice on me whatever whatever whatever
this [ __ ] guy thinks that's what it
is it ain't a germaphobe you know he's
like ah i don't want the peasants to
touch me any you know that
i'm not gonna shake the peasant's hand
kind of [ __ ] um let's see if he does he
does the whole like he does the arm pull
or
he shakes the hand and then
then he uh he yanks him in real quick oh
yeah yeah yeah i've seen that because he
doesn't know how to shake a hand right
right he doesn't know yeah he's like oh
this is an alpha male move and it's like
right right
is this the gift yeah here we go there
we go that's it
the attorney general should question
omarosa another trump aide's under oath
america can't have the is present eating
and flushing national documents where
the [ __ ] is this from he is actually
trump and he's what is he doing is this
gotta be from years ago i would oh [ __ ]
like whenever that came out i mean cuz
uh
oh jesus christ i don't know when this
was uploaded but oh my god how the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] do we live in this
timeline please please someone reset the
timeline at home office this is getting
[ __ ] ridiculous
is there a vid i know she went on a
media tour
um
about the book
and it was a big deal because remember
she got sued they tried to sue her they
tried to stop it and they could they
couldn't stop the book
right
and it probably might be this reason why
they wanted to stop the book now she was
on big brother here here's some clips of
her on big brother um and
you know they were worried about that
too that what she would reveal in the
big brother house because you know it's
all live they don't have you know they
know it's not scripted or anything they
can't control what they say
and a lot of the [ __ ] that she would say
would be heard
would be revealed to the public let's
see um is this the same that's the same
screenshot i'm just looking to see if
there's a video does anyone know if
there's a video out there of omarosa
let's go to videos here
i've heard you know saying
[ __ ] about this book because i know she
she had to have done a book tour right
no i would imagine she yeah there's no
way that she didn't i mean that's a
pretty high profile thing to you know
leaves she
leaving that administration especially
she was was she one of the first people
i know she was one in like the first
kind of round or so
um
but i wouldn't be surprised
so it looks like there's a clip from don
lemon show on cnn
um of them talking about it but not
actually her
okay well
but it's just [ __ ] crazy that we have
to even discuss this [ __ ] that they're
[ __ ] eating [ __ ] documents and i i
proposed earlier because you remember
when he went and met putin the only
people in the room oh you know what the
movie's from what's that sorry the scene
of eating the paper yeah it's the red
dragon
oh yes he's eating this
yes that's right
that's that's one of that's a movie that
is one of my favorite movies with uh
philip seymour hoffman in it he plays
such a great character in that right
because he because he expects me to send
that video out in a second
everyone be looking for that on twitter
speaking of tweets on twitter this
morning you um you had a good one let me
let me find it here
um now you you redid it even though i
redid it for like accuracy purposes you
know yeah accuracy you you're just
scared of these fact checkers that's all
it is listen i'm terrified you keep
getting you know
who who uh tell tell the audience who
who fact check your statement again who
was the uh oh uh it's uh
checkyourfact.com it's a daily wire and
maybe some of you know who daley wire is
because that's ben shapiro and uh matt
walsh that's that group um why why would
they have a fact-checking website do you
think i don't know to add legitimacy of
their organization
you're saying what they would what they
do i mean here's they actually do report
they you know they do fact check and
they have it so i don't know if it's as
a means of like uh adding legitimacy to
their group or if it has to do with the
fact of like you know just having
articles where
you know that it backs them up
people are saying [ __ ] right that's what
it you know that's what i think it is is
that old people are saying type [ __ ]
here's here's here's gabe's tweet
i'll i'll i'll let you explain it here
yeah so uh if anyone's a a tiger king
fan then you'll understand who the [ __ ]
isn't who the [ __ ] isn't uh well so
you've got uh trump's white house
documents carol baskin's husband
and they can both be found in the septic
tank
[ __ ] carol baskin have you seen have
you seen the second season and i've i
watched a few episodes of the second
season and i'm like this [ __ ] is bananas
so this is the second season is good but
the
the one that the i don't know if it's a
mini series or if it's like an extension
but the doc antle story where they tell
about document oh my god you gotta go
watch that dude you gotta go watch that
one
so there's [ __ ] yeah that's i didn't
yeah there's a second season of tiger
king and then there's like doc antle
tiger king type thing and i think it's i
don't know three or four episodes so
it's a couple two or three hours long
well there's also uh there's also the
there's two
possibly mini series there was one with
nicholas cage and and then he was like
i'm not doing anymore because it's not
relevant and then there's the one with
uh kate mckinnon
and others where oh you're talking about
where they're gonna do the movie or
whatever it's a it's a show it's uh joe
versus carol i think is what it's called
uh and they filmed it so is it actually
about them and it's it's parody or is it
like based on the true events it's based
on it's a it's a drama from what i
understand uh and it's based on the
events or at least you know the events
that we we've we know or at least have
been revealed um but yeah it's the it's
them the two between them they're feud
them going at each other right but you
know the best part about this whole
[ __ ] stupid story about him eating
and flushing documents is tiger king is
back in the timeline again we get tiger
gabe brings tiger king right back in i
mean he was recently he was he was
brought in the timeline a week or two
ago because his 22-year sentence was
21 years so you know yeah well that's
part of the um the second season where
his lawyers are trying to get a
re-sentencing hearing right and and they
did get it apparently and he got reduced
one year um
do you think do you think joe is guilty
do you think he's guilty
i mean
i mean you watch the [ __ ] first
series come on yeah yeah yeah he i mean
you know you're hiring me do you think
he burned the zoo the the the alligator
pit or whatever it is you think he
burned that do you think he burned it
like they like something
i don't do i remember that wait yeah
well yeah they
burnt down and he accused the
documentary maker uh what's his name oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah you need to
go back and rewatch you gotta re-watch
tiger king every six months to stay up
with this stuff yeah dude remember
remember when he was like i will not
financially recover from this
exactly all of those things were like
oops it went up all the footage all this
and that like it's all stuff that i
guarantee was on some insurance claim
you know right
well
i mean i mean
you know it's kind of like
when i was watching the show
right because we're talking about the
beginning of the pandemic when that
tiger king started and netflix hit it
big yeah that series airing at that time
like there could be no better timing for
a netflix here because i mean it
probably would have been popular but
there's no way it would be as as
known right now as it is because of when
it comes oh yeah you know i mean it was
billions of people sitting at home and
having to watch tv right i mean it was
i remember i was on i was on set uh and
i was filming i was doing a film and uh
somebody sent me the trailer because it
was it was like as things it was the
beginning of march right and everyone's
like oh uh i don't know and the people
like leaving going home to their
families and stuff i mean while we're on
set trying to finish this right the
entire country is freaking out right
yeah because san francisco shuts down
the nba
they they cancel everything right they
just call it all off yeah so i'm on set
and everyone's like oh well this like
this pa
ended up going home and they were
freaked out so we got us up for this and
we got to suffer this and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on this is insane
and then somebody sent me this trailer
for tiger king and i was like whoa this
looks nuts and then like two days later
they're like hey by the way
everything's shutting down and then
tiger king comes out and it was like
man
[ __ ] is crazy right now in real life
it could be way worse right right right
and i will watch and enjoy someone
else's pain and misery obviously you
know what you know
we're talking about these flushing
documents and all this [ __ ] eating
documents like literally
we had tiger king as the [ __ ]
president of the united states like we
probably would have been better off for
four years of having joe exotic be our
president literally that
i mean they were trying to get him to be
and even in the second even in the
second season they they touched on that
the whole like those guys were at the
january 16th
rally they were trying to get trump the
party right they left but the fact that
they had raised all this money they flew
private they put the banners on the
buses they got this they got that like
you know he's trying to get this guy to
run for president which is insane uh
especially because
uh he
he's just dude tiger king joke exotic is
such a mess man a mess a message
like like next to hot mess in the
dictionary there's the head shot
of joe exotic and i'm not talking like
his mug shot i'm talking about him on
the [ __ ] tiger you know where he's
got like the
right yeah i mean
i mean when he was like oh yeah you know
what sells really low the leopard uh
right yeah underwear you know yeah and
you're like why would i [ __ ]
like
all places i'm gonna find and buy other
underwear especially like someone with a
an animal print on it i'm gonna go to
this
sanctuary as he called it or whatever uh
no i i'm okay you know even though he
did say was a hot selling item which i'm
like man i guess there's some [ __ ]
weird people out there well you know
from this guy this this story is crazy i
i'm gonna do the uh don jr did you see
because we talked about midas touch
yesterday did you see midas touch also
entered the chat with tucker and don jr
i saw that yeah i got an email this
morning from parlor from my troll
account um they're talking about it over
there too they're sending emails out
over there too so oh um you know i i
wish you could join us for the uh
don jr
but don't worry i will say this
potentially maybe possibly probably
a video
is coming out with a i may have had a
facetime call with don jr again oh okay
even though i told him never to call me
back he
he keeps going
do you block his number and he gets a
new burner number or what what's the
yeah pretty somehow you know i'm also
like i feel fine kind of bad for him
because he's got like right now to talk
to you know
well you can't you can't call our dog to
his dad for sure right i mean he's busy
flushing papers down the toilet so well
you know he's got a mouthful of
documents he calls me and i just got to
say
hey man you know what's going on but in
this call he uh was defending joe rogan
of bad words
we'll see how that goes we'll see well
we'll be looking for that on the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends thanks
thanks for stopping by gabe we'll see
you tomorrow hang out hang out after the
break we'll talk about the john du
junior video right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
and the shitless roundup where we round
up all the sweetie tweets and trendy
trends i promised you
i promised you some don jr booger sugar
junior content and boy do we have it
here
um but you guys seen our little rant
yesterday with the um let's let's make
this a little bigger ariel okay
you seen our rant yesterday about minus
touch and um
how the the right-wing media is accusing
them
of uh
being responsible for the